c'est toujours leur de babar issa avec
bravo loto le jeu 100% gratuit qui peut
changer ta vie tu télécharges l'api
jeter gris et tente de remporter jusqu'à
un million d'euros sans rien faire bravo
l'auto facile d'être riche
c'est le ping pong ni comment se
démarquer de ces trois points on fait
d'abord une balle de des journaux je
pense que je vais me battre
alors ça c'est la vraie d'échauffement
que je perds toujours pour donner je
crois que je vais me battre et je te
dirai après pourquoi je t'ai match c'est
parce que j'en ai vraiment ce que je
vais te rassure je pense que je vais te
[ __ ] aime bien les slips toi pizzaïolo
des gamins oui oui oui tu perds ton slip
à env est un bon joueur c'est un aphte
punk c'est à toi tu es dans balle de
match balle de match après je vois rien
[Applaudissements]
c'est bon je compris ta technique du
match aller l'a uni
cet arrière
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]